what's up guys helen here now i don't
know about some of you luddites but i
actually revel in the convenience of
modern technology still enjoying these
addictive pleasures does mean you're
bowing down at the altar of big tech and
really one company in particular google
which along with its parent company
alphabet has infiltrated just about
every aspect of our lives we use google
chrome to browse the internet android to
power our phones nest to keep our homes
cool fitbit to track our literal steps
youtube to watch our favorite content
and the list just keeps going and
surprise surprise being beholden to a
corporate overlord isn't without its
downfalls i mean this is the company
that collects a truly omniscient amount
of information about you in my case 1.97
gigabytes which begs the very simple
question is google evil to answer that
we're going to have to understand the
changing role data plays in our lives
and the dubious ways google has grown to
monetize them so join us for this
wisecrack edition on how google got evil
in order to assess just how sinister
google might be we first need to
understand how search engines work cast
your minds back to the year 1996 a
simpler time when pokemon numbered only
151
also a time when search engines really
sucked then search engines would rank
pages based on how many times a search
phrase appeared which is kind of dumb
after all if your friend's choking on a
bagel bite you don't want the first
website you click on to be the phrase
heimlich maneuver written a thousand
times enter the stanford wonderkins of
90's tech larry page and sergey brin
they radically envisioned the internet
as a literal web with different web
pages connected via links see larry
sergey i.e the benifer of the internet
wagered that the more referrals any one
page has the more important that page
must be like how on a map the more roads
that lead to a city the more important
that city probably is so larry sergey
set out to literally map the internet
via algorithm and the two were able to
create a system in which more popular
and relevant websites rose to the top of
the search results it was a massively
ambitious undertaking that would
fundamentally change the internet
forever by 1998 what started as a
doctorate thesis matured into a
massively successful company google
after one year google was already
handling 3.5 million searches a day by
2000 that number had grown to 18 million
but while google was undoubtedly the
best search engine around the company
still hadn't monetized that's because
monetizing created an ethical quandary
there was massive concern for example
that google might let companies
artificially buy their way to a higher
search ranking but larry sergey decided
this would be manipulative and harmful
to the consumer so they came up with two
big breakthroughs the first breakthrough
was adwords you know that sponsored
content at the top of your google search
results that says add this allowed
google to rake in money from companies
trying to get their products seen
without creating a perverse pay-to-play
system the second breakthrough was the
company's motto don't be evil this would
act as google's moral compass and the
company's early years encouraging them
to forego short-term gains in order to
be good for the world they've since
dropped the tagline which bold move and
for a while google did indeed seem to be
the good guys but as google embarked on
its advertising venture it soon realized
it could create tailor-made ads to suit
each customer this was a real game
changer for an advertising industry that
previously could only try to target
consumers via vague demographics that's
because google had a secret weapon all
the data from your previous searches
thus it knew a lot about you while this
data was once only used to refine search
results google quickly realized that it
offered key insights which could be used
to better serve us ads according to
harvard's psychologist shashana zubov
the collecting and monetizing of
personal data marked a big inflection
point not just for google but for
society as a whole see google had
pioneered what duboff dubs surveillance
capitalism i.e a new economic order that
claims human experience as free raw
material for hidden commercial practices
of extraction prediction and sales in
other words we as an amalgamation of our
data have become the product which
depending on your perspective is
probably explicitly evil a little bit
icky or somewhere in between especially
if you like me keep getting served
personalized ads for bagel bites on
every single website and once google saw
how profitable creeping could be they
really doubled down on the business
model in 2007 it acquired the company
doubleclick which had a simple mo
serving up personalized banner ads on
websites all over the internet
doubleclick essentially created the
current advertising hellscape that we
live in now google didn't just know
everything that you were searching for
via doubleclick it also knew which
websites you were visiting which
articles you were reading movies you
were watching close you were shopping in
2010 then google ceo eric schmidt
famously declared we know where you are
we know where you've been we can more or
less know what you're thinking about
which doesn't sound not evil but it's
really not an exaggeration almost every
product the company has is dedicated to
collecting your data from gmail scanning
your inbox to fitbit tracking your sleep
patterns to google maps tracking your
last trip to the liquor store hey it's
five o'clock somewhere all said and done
it's not that google has the capacity to
store at least 15 exabytes of data or 15
billion gigabytes and a sizable portion
of that is dedicated to storing our
personal data now some of you may be
asking what's really the harm in being
served personalized ads well when you
look more closely there's a lot of
potential problems for one google has
used its data collecting to help
companies partake in exploitative
pricing specifically that means setting
whatever price points they choose for
each individual customer based on their
data and personalization can have
particularly harmful effects on people
in dire economic straits for years
google used its data collection to help
payday loan lenders advertise to
vulnerable potential borrowers google's
even been caught giving data to the
police based on keyword searches that
makes me shiver when i recall all the
times i've googled where does the
creator of vagobytes live and best ways
to avenge your friend but even when it's
just using data to decide what
information to feed you online the
results can be low-key disastrous for
example you might think a fringe
political cause is a lot more sensible
than it really is simply because you
served a continual stream of ads and
youtube videos on the topic in fact
researchers believe that algorithms
played a key role in radicalizing people
by serving them progressively more
extreme content and it's this very
mechanism which has given oxygen to so
many of the most absurd and stupid
conspiracy theories of recent years many
of which thrived on google's own youtube
and how did that turn out in reality
you are actually in a giant
planetarium slash terrarium
slash soundstage and sure even if you're
completely on team personalized content
that doesn't really clear google of all
evil related charges the fundamental
problem remains when a company is
sitting on so much of your personal
information there is ample opportunity
for abuse in countries where google
operates it's forced to play ball with
local authorities in rare instances
google has even been forced to turn over
user account information to less than
stellar governments like saudi arabia
and while plans have since been
shuttered google was even developing a
special search engine to be compliant
with china's rigorous state censorship
but google doesn't have to be
collaborating with oppressive
governments to potentially influence
your life and your choices as zuboff
explained surveillance capitalists have
learned to tune herd and condition our
behavior with subtle and subliminal cues
rewards and punishments that shunt us
toward their most profitable outcomes in
this way zuboff notes our behavior is
being intervened upon touched coaxed
modified contaged influenced in all of
these ways that are designed to be
undetectable to us zubalf argues that
this behavioral modification born out of
excessive data collection and the
personalization it facilitates even robs
us of our future tense which is the
essence of free will in other words do i
even like bagel bites anymore or am i
merely a carb hungry sheep being
controlled by the man but why are we so
okay with google owning the sum of our
life experiences why are we cool with a
business model that postures us free
will simultaneously making us pay by
handing over our valuable data well on
one level it's because we're not totally
sure what exactly is happening which is
also true of me whenever i sit behind
this microphone as zuboff explains
google has learned to employ a range of
rhetorical political and technological
strategies to obfuscate these processes
and their implications effectively it
hides its shady practices from consumers
while heavily lobbying the government
for the right to continue them but
there's more according to bruce schneier
our continued reliance on google despite
its creepiness comes down to the fact
that we overestimate the value of free
we consume more of something than we
should when it's free we pressure others
to consume it free warps our normal
sense of cost versus benefit and people
end up trading their personal data for
less than it's worth on the surface it
seems like we're getting a great deal
with google but the truth of that matter
is that we're handing the company some
of our most sensitive information
information that's tremendously valuable
to companies trying to advertise to us
indeed personal data is the fastest
growing industry in america based on
current trends our data could be worth
197.7 billion dollars by 2022 making it
bigger than the nation's entire
agricultural output but as valuable as
it is we're of course not compensated
for it as journalist rana foruhar argues
when our data is what's being collected
we have a right to know how much it's
worth and then decide as a society if we
should be receiving some of that value
ourselves and when you think about how
many bagel bites your data could buy you
that argument becomes pretty persuasive
so is google kind of evil for sure
whether they're using reams of data to
manipulate your behavior via
hyper-targeted ads making conspiracy
theories seem mainstream or colluding
with bad actors like digital loan sharks
or oppressive governments google's power
is overwhelming to contemplate meanwhile
their willingness to use that power for
good is underwhelming but what do you
guys think are we being too harsh on the
very company which lets us publish these
videos to reach all our lovely fans or
are we hitting on a fundamental truth
that for too long we've been willing to
sacrifice privacy for convenience let us
know what you think in the comments big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and be sure to check out our
podcast obliterate that subscribe button
like google did to your privacy and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you